hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm Brad Lambert Brad or Lambert on
Instagram make sure to follow this guy
he's he he was John ham stunt double and
baby driver right now he's a good friend
of mine he's a producer I'm trying to
get it involved in all of his movies
that's the only reason I'm friends with
him it's working out break it out I'm
the lead and all of them now Brad what's
that shirt you have on
STAR Labs someone's a fan of the CW
shows arrow season six this is a real
trailer I'm excited for this I love
season five season five was fantastic I
thought it was really I'm on par with
season two they went back to basics yeah
cuz i binge the whole show this year
just love Stephen Amell I know Stephens
great question ut Melissa T now what
yeah I are the only one in the world
let me just bounce back real quick I
think it was fine when they were in like
the very flirty kind of early stages
their relationship once they got engaged
I mean it really went deep into that
relationship space I think it got to be
a little too much I mean it's a little
annoying with the whole life will they
get back together won't they this is
like yeah make a decision all right I'm
a fan like a huge fan of the first two
seasons I thought that was phenomenal
storytelling TV all together in season
five got back to Oliver Queen yeah that
was it that was my mom shows a bomb
season right there
Oh patron the day shout-out for not to
me to rhyme today
[Music]
those are arrows now I was running
around the city during the day and
managing it as bear well running around
at night
frightening criminals as a vigilante
that really would make me a superhero
but I'm not a no pastor there
he's just the mayor guys thank you very
much every time that I'm not there right
there I'm targeting the threats that are
out there and the threats that are
undoubtedly coming any reservations
concerns about what comes next
of course Katie Cassidy's back yeah this
is regular now
what happened
nice bag time how to reach me
I wouldn't call having a friend who
helps you gets into trouble eating this
is true carefully now yeah you know
something maybe a mayor should number
[Music]
the time of vigilantes is coming to an
end people take the law into their own
hands
you sure at me a long time ago there
were no true heroes and villains only
women's and losses and do I know which I
know I know that I appreciate the played
and the Trust doesn't come
[Music]
[Music]
Ireland is on fire this is going to be
an incredibly insightful
okay okay Thursday can't come soon
enough let's get it man it's really
getting dark it's really getting dark
man yeah it's really getting I feel like
a lot of the because we don't know
everyone who survived off the island
they just killed off most of the cats
I doubt it I'm going to assume that the
mother to his child is dead that's
that's a fair easy assumption to come to
see that part of this of the show I'm
not too sure how I'm gonna feel watching
those scenes am I gonna enjoy watching
Oliver Queen try to be a dad I know
that's a part of like giving the show
more of a heart and all that but the
same time like I just kind of not really
care about it already you know that
really gonna be like a distraction from
all the other stuff that'll be way more
interesting you know Slade Wilson seems
like he's gonna be heavily involved in
this season which which could be really
cool people have been asking for him to
come back since he left the show yeah
and when he came back for what the one
or two episodes and he's a five huge
huge move yeah and now they're all for
that because he is an incredible
character yeah and Katie Cassidy has all
these different thanks Barry with Katie
Cassidy coming back to the show she's
gonna be a series regular again I
actually feel like she fits the role of
black siren pretty well I find that
impressive because she was a pretty good
Laurel I thought her storyline did get
it a kind of annoying where they were
like what do we do with her yeah and I
didn't fully by Laurel becoming a
vigilante I just never did she we
haven't had enough training I don't care
how much motivation you have strewth you
have not had enough training to be
fighting the streets with these people I
just don't buy it yeah but then you know
like there's a whole different
background in history with who black
siren is from earth-2 tirely different
person that I'm more on board with and I
think she does like the evil stuff good
I find her just way more intriguing
watch and I believe the conflicts that
that Oliver Queen runs into because of
his history with Laurel and it's hard to
just differentiate the two he has to go
you're entirely different person when
they have this same exact face and voice
my curiosity for where the seasons gonna
go is you know how they have that
interesting format were 10 to 15 minutes
of an episodes dedicated to an origin
black backs yeah yeah season 5 that all
came full circle yep to the point where
he becomes Green Arrow he's heading back
to Starling city so I'm wondering like
are they gonna do some type of flashback
are they gonna do a flash-forward
or like what are they gonna be doing
this time or is it just gonna be take
place in the immediate present time that
would be a nice change up if they don't
have the flashback they don't have the
fly because sometimes the flashbacks or
not but I know I feel like they're still
gonna have a dome yeah it's such a huge
part of the show I don't think it'll be
as prevalent yeah and as happen so often
you know as last time it might be every
other episode whereas before it was
every single episode yeah black Canary's
back we'll see how that turns out twice
hot obviously they didn't show like you
mentioned earlier the you know the main
guys everybody yeah but obviously Slade
was on the island and we've seen Slade
yeah yeah so there's gotta be a way they
survived like most of them have it I
take it the mom died what I don't want
the show to do and I get really annoyed
when shows of comic book characters
spent too much time on this you know
Felicity and Diggle or back but they're
all traumatized and they don't want to
be heroes anymore they're guys waiting a
whole like 6 to 10 episodes or just get
back to the team already I'm tired of
this get on it come on I didn't see
Diggle at a lot of the promos I saw I
forgot her actual name Felicity yeah I'm
she's my TV show crushed by the way
yeah you pervert you're actually you
know the personality nerd girl cause
she's a full package
she's what every you know YouTube
comments your watch I am excited for it
and the marketing for season 6 they have
to be like way more discreet because
they can't give away what happens at the
the cliffhanger of season 5 we already
know that black siren is back we know
other
Black Canary is back you know Slade
Wilson's alive but like our main heroes
the ones we've really grown invested
into who's alive there
hey I'm hoping Malcolm Merlyn is
actually dead he keeps dying he keeps
coming back I mean I'm not a fan of
Oliver sister Thea I'm not anymore yeah
she just kind of became a character that
just kind of hung around the character
development with Oliver he saw everyone
he loved low up yeah on the island so
that'll be interesting to see where this
picks up and what happens in that
transition of finding out who survives
etcetera and then him dealing with the
repercussions of that and it seems like
the issues of the broth des brought ruff
- ruff ruff - Brad Bravo TV like that's
really gonna come back to really haunt
and full circle and and the faculty has
to go out there and it starts off with
him being like guys I'm not the arrow
we're American makes the him having to
conceal his identity even that much
harder because one of my favorite parts
of the arrow season 2 was when like he
had to turn himself in cuz Slade was I
was exposing him after a while when
people keep going I think Oliver Queen's
the arrow eventually he's bound to get
caught and you had a theory this might
end with him joining legends of tomorrow
yeah I mean we've all seen like the
rumors of this show ending I mean every
show has to end
Stephen Amell does such an incredible
job as Oliver Queen and the green arrow
that I don't see them just kind of
dropping him altogether he's a great
leader agreed so I think he would make
sense to be put on legends of tomorrow
and or have some type of role in the
flash but I'm also excited to see the
crossover for for this season obviously
with all four shows now ramping up and
kind of getting their feet wet I think
it's gonna be exciting to kind of see
everybody come together well before we
wrap up this video picture the day shout
out for Natalie to Ron she's from
Ireland
she's a beautiful gal she's great they
call a rich accent I can't really do her
Irish accent I can't even do a normal
Irish accent thanks thanks American Brad
one time I was telling people like I
don't watch the the DC shows on CW like
way earlier this year and she was one of
the people like one
you people who was like you got to watch
it da da da da da and I was like fine
I'll watch it then I ended up loving it
so I associate a lot of why I've watched
arrow with her and she's one of our top
patrons right now she's on tinder and
Ireland so go find her if you're in
Ireland she is looking for some good
Irish don't find her no you guys aren't
worth it you an American
thanks so much for being part of our
patron I thanks so much for this one
thanks for encouraging me to watch a
great show like arrow I even like the
season someone else likes you're the
bomb the bomb lady anyway guys subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow bread our
Lambert on Instagram I'm telling you
guys it's one hell of an Instagram
[Laughter]